c'est dans ses bureaux à l'abri des
regards indiscrets qu'un groupe de
chercheurs prépare l'avenir et de ip
vous connaissez on assemble des
composantes électroniques plastique nous
sommes le système qui contrôle le lit
d'hôpital le système de divertissement
dans un avion le système de contrôle
dans la thermopompe de piscine
l'entreprise a décidé de pousser plus
loin son expertise en sérigraphie et en
chimie pour créer des matériaux avancés
et transformer les objets qui meublent
notre quotidien
si on transforme tout ça en un morceau
avec la matière avant c'est l'angle
moléculaire qui est une encre
conductrice qu'on a inventé en
partenariat avec le centre national de
recherche canadiens on arrive à ypres y
met un circuit sur une feuille
inflexible on vient placer dans le moule
les deux éléments à la fois le circuit
et la partie graphique et on vient à
injecter une résine de manière à faire
en sorte que notre circuit fasse partie
de la surface qu'on rend notre surface
intelligente les plastiques recyclés
utilisée pour sa fabrication fait de ce
système de contrôle pour voiture une
pièce peu coûteuses ont réduit grosso
modo de 50 à 80 % les coûts de
production de même pièce fonctionne à
l'autre produit phare de e2 ip c'est
celui-ci on les appelle les surfaces
usinés
électromagnétique qui permettent pour
les nouvelles technologies
5 g qui s'en viennent notamment dans les
villes intelligentes de pouvoir propager
le signal plus facilement sans avoir
nécessairement besoin de multiplier les
antennes autres procédés novateurs dans
cette usine de ville saint-laurent le
graphite
un minéral naturel est utilisée pour
extraire le gras faible c'est un
matériau qui a des propriétés qui a pour
effet d'augmenter de façon significative
la force mécanique des produits la
conductibilité de certains produits
c'est très imperméables c'est en
psychose et le graphène est employé
comme additif dans plusieurs produits
comme les capots de camions pour les
rendre plus légers donc moins
énergivores au québec la place de ce
secteur ne cesse de croître
ça représente 340 350 entreprises
essentiellement de la pme et une masse
critique de plus de 3 ans 3000 employés
c'est aussi le filière en pleine
ébullition dans le monde
marché qui représentera plus de 100
milliards de dollars américains dans
quatre ans et si maxime bertrand radio
canada morrell